[Musique]
shigeru miyamoto michel en scène hideo
kojima cliff bleszinski sid meier yuzuki
peter molyneux kim swift mois et vous
toutes et tous dans la salle
d'après vous quel est le point commun
entre toutes ces personnes à part leur
sex-appeal et bien elles peuvent tout
créer des jeux vidéo vraiment il n'ya
rien de bien sorcier derrière la
création vidéoludique
le plus compliqué finalement c'est de se
détacher des idées reçues qu'on peut
avoir sur ce milieu car ce sont elles
qui nous limite et nous empêchent
d'expérimenter après je comprends
vraiment qu'on puisse trouver sa
inaccessible moi la première
j'ai très longtemps cru que ce n'était
pas pour moi pourtant je viens d'une
famille qui jouent aux jeux vidéo
mon père et ma mère sont des joueurs qui
fait que je joue depuis aussi loin que
je me souvienne le jeu vidéo a toujours
été le média sur lequel je passais le
plus de temps jean consommer énormément
et c'est devenu pour moi une vraie
passion et pourtant malgré cette passion
dévorante
à aucun moment j'imaginais qu'il était
possible pour moi de créer des jeux
vidéo un jour avec le recul je pense
savoir pourquoi dans les médias
mainstream et la pop culture
on baigne dans des représentations très
cliché des développeurs de jeu quand
j'étais plus jeune j'étais persuadé que
c'était une vocation réservé à des
génies à des crack de l'informatique
mais avec le don de la programmation et
je croyais aussi plus ou moins
consciemment que c'était quelque chose
de réservé aux garçons
je ne vais pas réellement de modèle au
calme identifier
je pense que vous l'aurez remarqué sur
mon petit diaporama de tout à l'heure
mais les grosses stars du milieu mais
idole quand j'étais plus jeune était
quasiment tous des hommes
ce qui fait qu'avec tous ces a priori il
était quasiment impossible pour mon
cerveau de faire la connexion entre moi
et le fait de pouvoir créer des jeux
vidéo et c'est resté comme ça jusqu'à
cette merveilleuse période de la vie
qu'est le lycée où on demande à des ados
la 12 des adolescents pardon de savoir
là tout de suite maintenant quel métier
ils voudront faire pour le restant de
leurs jours
sans pression et je sais pas vous mais
moi cette question à me stresser pas mal
à l'époque j'étais vraiment convaincu
que tout allait se jouer à cet instant
pour déterminer le reste de ma vie
en plus j'avais la chance d'avoir des
parents qui m'encourageait à être
exigeante pour mon futur
il tenait à ce que je puisse faire un
métier dans lequel j'allais pouvoir
m'épanouir tout simplement
alors j'ai réfléchi quelle était la
chose qui me motive est vraiment dans la
vie qu'est-ce que j'accepterais de faire
tous les jours plusieurs heures par jour
jusqu'à la retraite et je pense pas
vraiment vous surprendre en vous disant
que c'est le jeu vidéo qui est revenu à
chaque fois
pour autant j'ai jamais osé en parler à
ma conseillère d'orientation j'avais
peur qu'ils me disent que ce n'était pas
un vrai métier
alors j'ai refoulé cette idée jusqu'au
dernier moment où par hasard je suis
tombé sur le site internet d'une école
de jeux vidéo et là j'ai découvert
quelque chose d'incroyable préparez-vous
vraiment en fait savoir faire des jeux
vidéo ça s'apprend
il a vraiment fallu que je constate
l'existence de cette école pour intégrer
que savoir faire des jeux vidéo c'était
un métier et que comme tout métier ça ça
prenait alors une fois cette première
barrière mentale de franchi je me suis
renseigné
quels étaient les différentes filières
de ses métiers et après avoir eu mon bac
je me suis dirigé vers le game design
mêlant notamment ma première année
d'études supérieures
j'ai rencontré un nouvel obstacle alors
celui là il est bien connu
je pense que vous l'avez déjà tous et
toutes déjà expérimenté peut-être que
vous l'expérimenté à l'heure actuelle
dans tous les cas j'ai l'impression
qu'on peut pas trop y échapper j'ai eu
un gros syndrome de l'imposteur ou
plutôt j'ai eu un gros complexe
d'infériorité vis-à-vis de mes camarades
de classe quand je suis arrivé je me
suis rendu compte qu'ils avaient tous un
bien plus gros bagage technique que moi
que ce soit leurs lectures en game
design leur culture vidéoludique ou
leurs connaissances des moteurs de jeu
j'avais l'impression que mes
connaissances à moi n'étaient pas
suffisantes et que je ne pourrai jamais
rien faire d'intéressant avec mais
heureusement est arrivé mon premier
stage dans un studio de jeux où j'ai pu
pour la première fois mettre la main à
la pâte et ce jour là et bien cette
deuxième barrière est tombé puisque j'ai
pu me rendre compte par moi même qui
n'était pas nécessaire d'être un expert
pour pouvoir bidouiller et créer des
trucs cool ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que apprendre à faire des jeux vidéo
c'est très empirique comme du dicton
c'est en faisant qu'on devient un faisan
tout à fait je vois que mathieu et quand
j'ai compris ça j'ai pu continuer mes
études d'une manière plus sereine et
avec beaucoup plus de confiance en moi
et une fois mon diplôme en poche et ma
détermination à son maximum
eh bien j'ai pu trouver mon premier job
en game design dans un studio à paris et
là j'étais prête à mettre en application
tout ce que j'avais appris et je me
réjouissait à l'idée de pouvoir
travailler dans un espace finalement
dans lequel j'aurai enfin les moyens de
maison
sion car travailler dans un studio pour
moi ça voulait dire travailler avec des
gens de tous les domaines d'expertisé du
matériel adapté et travailler sur des
périodes de développement plus longue
pour mener à bien des projets plus
ambitieux
c'était finalement se détacher de la
frustrante débrouille étudiante mais là
bas j'ai quand même rencontré une
troisième et dernière barrière
j'ai très vite déchanté quand je me suis
rendu compte qu'avec les moyens qu'on
avait à disposition on produisait des
jeux qui ne me faisais rien ressentir du
tout il y avait un énorme décalage entre
ce que je m'attendais à faire et la
réalité de mon métier dans l'industrie
et il faut savoir qu'à cette période de
ma vie je commençais de plus en plus à
ressentir le besoin de m'exprimer de
transmettre des choses et pour moi de
jeu vidéo était parfait pour ça c'était
ça qui m'avait donné envie de faire ce
métier et c'était ça qui alimente et ma
passion depuis le début malheureusement
cette envie était en totale opposition
avec l'esprit du studio dans lequel
j'étais alors peut-être qu'il ya des
gens de mon âge dans la salle qui se
reconnaîtront dans ce témoignage ou pas
mais j'avais l'impression d'être le
cliché parfait de la fameuse génération
y
je ne fais d'accord sur rien mais alors
rien du tout que ce soit le management
la direction artistique où la
représentation des personnages moi qui
luttent activement pour une plus grande
impunité dans le jeu vidéo
ça me fend le coeur d'être obligée de
perpétuer des représentations daté et
sexiste avec lesquels j'étais en profond
désaccord
et autant vous dire que pour moi ça a
été une période assez difficile où j'ai
dû remettre en question tout ce parcours
d'avenir que je pensais tout tracé ce
que je voulais faire dans la vie ce fait
des jeux certes mais des jeux qui me
plaisait alors j'étais là dans cet entre
deux
avec cette d'un côté cette envie partir
et de l'autre et bien cette peur de
quitter le seul milieu professionnel
dans lequel finalement j'avais la
possibilité de m'épanouir et c'est resté
comme ça un long moment jusqu'à ce que
je joue au jeu qui a changé ma vie
le jeu qui m'a fait tout remettre en
question
peut-être en avez vous déjà entendu
parler il a eu un certain succès sur la
scène indépendante
je veux parler dunderdale si je n'avais
pas joué à ce jeu je ne ferai peut-être
même pas devant vous ce soir
[Musique]
pourquoi ce jeu est si important pour m
et bien déjà parce que je le trouve
excellent je le trouve vraiment
intelligent et innovants dans ses
mécaniques mais c'est surtout parce
qu'il a été capable de me faire
ressentir des choses qu'aucune grosse
production n'a été capable de me faire
ressentir jusque ce jeu m'a fait rire
pleurer
il m'a transmis des messages d'amour de
tolérance de remise en question et tout
ça avec très peu de moyens il faut
savoir que ce jeu a été fait quasi
entièrement par toby fox une seule
personne est avec un moteur de jeu très
accessible que tout le monde pourrait
utiliser
alors quand j'ai réalisé ça et une pince
vraiment encore retourné le cerveau une
deuxième fois
mais s'il lui a pu le faire pourquoi pas
moi alors j'ai décidé de suivre la même
voie
et attention âmes sensibles j'ai décidé
de quitter le studio dans lequel j'étais
en refusant un cd dans le jeu vidéo
laisse imaginer la tête que mes parents
ont pu faire quand je leur ai dit mais
ça m'a passé plus peur que ça et sans
structure
eh bien je me suis lancé dans la grande
aventure du développement indépendant
avec montjeu propagande à j'allais enfin
pouvoir utiliser ce média pour
transmettre des messages avec lesquels
j'étais en accord et croyez moi je me
suis fait plaisir
j'ai fait un casting
aussi inclusif et diversifié que je le
voulais j'ai pu aborder des sujets
antimilitariste ce qui aurait été
compliqué de faire dans un studio
bref j'ai rencontré la liberté créative
total et il faut savoir qu'en parallèle
de sa à la même époque se déroulait le
lancement de l'association les internet
qui inciter les femmes à venir faire des
trucs sur youtube et à ne pas avoir peur
de sortir des clichés genre et de la
plateforme en voyant ça on se dit que ça
pourrait être cool de garder une trace
vidéo de mon projet que je pourrais en
plus partager à mes proches pour qu'ils
puissent voir où j'en étais c'est donc
là qu'est née ma chaîne youtube la
développeuse du dimanche dans laquelle
je m'efforçais vraiment d'être la plus
accessible et pédagogique possible pour
que tout le monde puisse comprendre ce
que je faisais alors les semaines
passent mon projet avance bien
j'ai sorti plusieurs vidéos et je vois
bien qu'au fur et à mesure je ne suis
plus suivies uniquement par mes proches
mais aussi par des curieux et curieuses
qui s'intéressent au développement de
jeu tout simplement et voyez-vous ce que
je suis venu vous raconter ici ce soir
c'est ce que je cherche à transmettre à
travers mes vidéos on vit à une époque
formidable
il existe des tas de moyens de faire des
jeux vidéo qui ne sont pas coûteux ou ou
vraiment qui demande beaucoup
d'expertisé je pense notamment à des
moteurs gratuit et accessible comme game
maker unity rpg maker toi une constructs
et on vit aussi une époque formidable
parce que je n'oublie pas l'existence
des game jam qui sont des événements
dans lesquels des professionnels et des
amateurs se rassemblent pour créer un
jeu vidéo en un week-end finalement il
suffit d'en avoir l'envi et bien entendu
un peu de temps pour pouvoir s'amuser et
créer des choses et je me réjouis de
voir que j'en ai motiver plus d'un
et plus d'une et bien à se lancer avec
ma chaîne je vais vous montrer quelques
images de jeux qui m'ont envoyé
ils sont tous plus cool et originaux les
uns que les autres
j'ai même reçu des témoignages de
parents donc les tentes qui m'ont dit
que leur fille et nièce
regardez ce que je faisais et que ça
leur avait donné envie de créer
et quand j'ai réalisé que j'avais
potentiellement un impact sur ces jeunes
filles qui pouvait se dire comme moi à
l'époque que va faire des jeux c'était
pas pour elle eh bien ça me conforte
dans l'idée qu'il faut que je continue
ce que je fais mais aussi qu'il faut que
je continue de transmettre ce message
autour de moi qui d'ailleurs s'applique
à plein de projets artistiques
ayez confiance en vous et rappelez vous
de ces trois choses il n'y a pas de
savoir ine il n'y a pas besoin d'être un
expert pour bidouiller créer et faire
des trucs cool
il n'y a pas besoin de gros moyens
techniques pour faire de bons projets
bref tout le monde peut créer des jeux
vidéo merci
m